I feel mixed about this story pap
there's an excellent new report in
Politico and Axios has already sort of
been covering this and it's Trump's lack
of work ethic okay Axios reported at the
beginning of the year that Donald Trump
is really just not doing that much work
he has hours and hours of so-called
executive time which I interpret as
tweets and porn probably and politico's
new report is that it's just getting
worse and worse
Trump sometimes has as many as nine
hours of executive time every single day
and on a good day Trump is doing no more
than three hours of actual work one
example would be last Tuesday where
Trump had only a half hour of phone
calls to CEOs he made a short statement
at a State Leadership Conference he had
a briefing with senior military leaders
that included his dinnertime and then he
had a meeting with chief of staff John
Kelly which was the first thing on his
schedule at 11:30 a.m. in the morning so
you might say David the guy's not doing
anything why are you feeling mixed
that's exactly why I recognize that the
job of president is just not meant to be
this cushy there's a lot to do and
people like President Obama did it
President Obama was likely reading
almost as much each day between
intelligence reports and personal
reading and other reading as Trump is
doing in total work in a day but the
reason I mixed is I don't want Trump
doing stuff right what we've learned is
that Trump has managed to do as much
damage as he's done while barely working
imagine if he actually took this as a
full-time job the amount of damage that
he'd be doing and that's why Pat when I
read about this I think well the guy is
a lazy and totally you know lacking work
ethic type of guy but at the same time
the more he does the worse off we are I
have to push back a little bit here
because I think Trump is doing plenty of
work this doesn't take into account the
amount of time that he spends tweeting
and through tweeting he's able to
connect directly with the American
public that's how he gets his message
out and the report also doesn't take
into account the amount of time that he
spends watching cable news by taking in
Fox News for
as per day he's caught up in all the
stories and he knows what's going on in
the world yeah that's the argument that
I mean you're joking but that's actually
the argument that the White House is
making which is he's doing a lot of
important things during unscheduled time
and of course that includes I guess
Twitter diplomacy and it includes
I guess they would say keeping abreast
of what's going on in the world which
means watching Fox and Friends and I get
it I mean Obama did lots of important
work things during that unscheduled time
but he was also scheduled most of the
day because he was after all the
presidents so when we wonder about how
Trump has so much time to tweet it's
because he's simply not doing that much
and again the question I what what I
want to hear from you about is yeah slam
his work ethic because I slam his work
ethic slam his effort because it's a
joke but imagine that damage he could
potentially do if he was actually
clocking 80 plus hours a week and the
the disappointing part is that no matter
what analysis we do this plays perfectly
with conservatives because they don't
want government doing that much they
often don't want the president even
having that much power so regardless of
whether it's because of laziness or
because of small government conservatism
there's a big contingent of the right
that likes the fact that the president
simply isn't doing very much send me
your thoughts I want to hear from you